[Music]
buddy I'm counted three one
two
three there I did it for you with the
beekeeper it was a lot of fun to
choreograph the fight sequences the
collaboration on the action has been
great the stunt team that we have has
been Second To
None you know David surrounds himself
with great talent and you're working
with Jeremy marinus who was my stunt
coordinator it was amazing to watch it
develop and then to shoot these long
takes of of Jason going through all the
qu we didn't double him in that we're
trying to keep things very real and very
efficient that's what Adam clay does he
uses what's available in the
environment he may get a gun take it
apart and turn it into a stabbing
weapon it's a very physical strenuous
activity we practice and practice and
practice you just grind on the
day it's something that would keep the
action fans on the edge of their seats
these scumbags really get taken
apart don't
move